và phát triển trường trong nước thủ bộ công thường dân mạnh, việc kiểm tra được
với các giản nghiệp kinh ra anh khi khí quyết đã khí,
bao gồm cả kinh cương là họ đồng kiểm tra chuyên đề được thực hiện
theo văn bản yêu cầu của cuộc phòng trong dự tiền thuộc ngăn hàng nhấn nước,
việc kiểm tra lại thực hiện theo kỳ từ tám của cuộc phòng trong dự tiền
nên thời gian thực hiện chỉ trong bỏ mụ tháng,
dự kiến xa tháng tám sẽ triển khai theo kỳ hoạt để thực hiện.
Kỳ này cuộc phòng li và phát triển thì trường trong nước thủ bộ công thường
đã hoàn thiện và bản hàng kỳ hoạt đang kiến hành thực hiện thông bảo với năm 2020.
Tuy nhiên, thông tiền có giành nghiệp năm trong kỳ hoạt kỳ chá chuyên đề
cuộc như thời gian kỳ chá khu thế chưa được thế lộ.